since the last technique I couldn't
figure out what I was doing wrong right
because the only solution I can come up
with is that I haven't faster than they
did which I know isn't right
what other timing I just I just couldn't
figure out the timing and spacing to to
not feel like I was late or so everyone
understands that that the futility of
relying on your speed if your technique
relies on speed then the success of your
technique is reliant upon also that your
opponent is slower than you so you would
be training in a martial art for people
who are slower than you the same thing
goes with strength if your technique is
reliant on strength then the unset
assumption is that your opponent is
weaker than you so all over the world
you have Aikido car and people from
other arts looking for speed and
strength and by default their training
for slower weaker people that is not the
point of a martial art the point of a
martial art is for people who are faster
than you stronger than you got it so
it's got to be from the get-go I know
that's not the solution move faster so
okay I still have a duration problem
right am I wasting movement am i taking
a step that's too large we get it that's
gonna add time to me so if you go to our
weapons - and you're trying to get right
trying to get that draw under a second
and hit that face shot it's if you try
to move faster and that's all you try to
do you're not going to hit anything what
you have to do is not do any wasted
movement
if when we when we film us and we have
an observer people are moving their
shoulders they're leaning their torso
right they have some weird ways that
they're presenting the gun out of the
holster and all that is adding those
fractions of a second in there and now
you're over the second if you go faster
like I said you miss so the idea is look
at what you don't need to do and don't
do it so the second as the deshi that
you feel I'm behind that's one of the
first places to look what am i doing
that does not need to be done that kind
of concept goes throughout all of your
training a lot of times we think in
positive angles positive aspects on how
to deal with the obstacles and problems
that come up in our training so we
always go what do I need to do right
what do I need to do to get better you
you'll have more success if you go what
do I need to stop doing to get better
maybe I need to stop staying up late at
night maybe I need to stop sleeping in
right maybe I need to stop cruising the
internet all night maybe I need to stop
wasting my time at work maybe I need to
stop that friendship maybe I need to
stop that crappy eating you get it maybe
I need to stop caving into my fears
maybe I need to stop being that old self
I don't want to be anymore you're going
to get way more out of it the second
thing you want to do in terms of these
duration issues is try to begin earlier
beginning earlier does not mean going
faster start earlier well starting
earlier is going to be a matter of
exception and perception is going to be
a matter of relaxation so if I have a
lot of anxiety in me my mind goes
egocentric my awareness goes down I
can't even tell when you starting to
move
I can't perceive that unconscious
inhalation you did
I can't perceive that weight shift you
did on the on the back foot to propel
yourself forward the kind of unconscious
opening and widening of the eyes and the
flaring of the nostrils all these
behavioral cues these these pre
aggression behavioral cues I just don't
see them why because I'm so nervous of
getting hit that my concern is me me me
so my mind goes egocentric my awareness
goes down and I have to start later not
until this huge event has already fully
manifested itself it's too late then
nothing works like that that's why they
have weight categories because you're
gonna get hit that's why they have no
weapons because you're gonna get killed
you have to catch these things way
before full manifestation and so you
need to be relaxed and awareness has to
be up and out you must reconcile that
urge towards egocentricity or you do not
get to start earlier then the third
thing is get more movement out of them
many times you guys stop them you don't
use the in-space to pull them in to keep
their full range of motion going so
their movement stops way before you
you're done you got you pull out the
movement out of them
Kieko and you almost got it buddy you
almost right so now you slow down
down in all those things yes they go on
top of your body conditioning right your
strength conditioning your flexibility
your mobility you have to assume those
things you can't be a slug you can't be
a couch potato this is this is not a
philosophy 101 class at a university
right you get that right
so once physically you're in the
ballpark then that is how to approach
this solution just accept from the
get-go that urge to go faster is not you
know when we were in the handgun class
before we had the laser rounds everyone
was making it everyone was making that
headshot and everyone was making it
under a second from shrimper but once we
got the marker and then you're like oh
man I can't even get under that second
so don't rush it'll make the technique
so as I was watching you when you rushed
you started cutting on the side of your
head and as a result you have to not aim
because your body the center line of
your body can't be used as a reference
you know in conjunction with that's not
a power line and you're not dominating
the center line now so both tactically
and biomechanically it's an inferior
thing
yeah so the anxiety right it's you can
probably get it more clearly outside of
the dojo where when we are being driven
in the reactivity via our fears we have
a resistance to what's happening and
that resistance usually manifests itself
in ways that we would described as
pushing away I might physically push
someone I might physically hit someone
but I might also go
I mean boundaries from you if I'm gonna
have boundaries you're gonna walk all
over me right and so if that if the
weapons work is generating this fear in
me and the tendency for fear is to start
some sort of pushing energy some sort of
resisting and get away from me then I
won't be able to generate the yen space
and the yen space comes from total
acceptance and total acceptance comes
from the opposite of egocentricity total
acceptance comes from an abandonment of
self do you understand that you you you
you have I have no openings because the
eye does not exist that's the idea so I
have no openings and I have nothing to
protect so I have nothing no reason to
push your way so when you come to attack
it's just I disappear and it pulls you
in make sure movement longer that
requires more time that gives me more
time so take the ski movements right
once you figure it out they're just
stupid techniques because you're just
running into it's like a kid's thing
like a little kid you wait till they get
in arm's reach and you touch their
forehead right and they're that kind of
thing but the hard part is it's not easy
to disappear it's not easy to let go
over so it's right and so that's where
the training rests so if you're going to
do weapons work and the whole time all
you're practicing is pushing away
pushing away pushing away you're wasting
your time remember we we understand Budo
training as fear reconciliation training
some of you are so young you just you
don't understand that yet there's no
need for it
your parents do right they might look at
you and in the secret moments of their
nights when they're in bed way I wish my
child wasn't so afraid because if you
live long enough you know how much you
suffer for that and if you're wise then
you know how much you will cause others
to suffer for that really until you
you've separated yourself enough from
the world and have enough years in there
what I'm saying you just have to kind of
take my word for it which is why when
when the [\h__\h] hits the fan I get the the
message or the letter thank God for
everything thank you for everything that
you did that you taught I couldn't have
done this without I would not have made
it through this without you
so it's easy when you're doing weapons
work and you hate it and you want it to
stop maybe I'm not even show up to
weapons class or maybe I'm gonna pick
your case you don't challenge me
or maybe I'm gonna slow things down so
I'm not challenged so I don't have to
bring this demon to the surface that I
have to wrestle with but every time you
do that you're wasting time
you're left with that fear you did
wrestle with that demon only you lost
you understand that demon did show up
and when you chose not to bring it all
the way into the light you lost you
already wrestled and you lost and
there's not many places in our lives
anymore where I have fear reconciliation
training I don't have it there was no
University course there's no mentoring
program where you go yeah I went to
trade school what was it fear fear trade
school that's not out there nobody talks
about it it's your you know if you're
Catholic and you got to go to your
marriage pre-marriage counseling but
some even raised there you can have the
kid no one talks about it there's no
book all the books are on you know
here's what birth looks like here's the
bonds no one braces the fear the terror
that's with you if you're honest from
the moment your child is in your
consciousness as your child
my mom told me that once before she said
you'll see when you have a child you're
gonna be forever terrified
yeah yeah yeah but it's true
so this place and this training this
practice is very important because if
you look outside where most people are
not doing this you can see that that
demon fear is winning it's everywhere in
every one solution is to intoxicate and
distract and that's not a victory that's
not the not wrestling you did wrestle
you lost you get it you lost so same
thing I know I admit it
weapons are terrifying who wants to get
hit with a stick I'm pretty sure that we
have an evolutionary gene in us that
says sticks bud we probably have it with
rocks to rocks by wolves bod right and
so here's somebody is swinging a stick
at you all that evolutionary history is
just coming right to the surface but you
know what good that's that that's why it
works you can think of it as a
divination ritual I'm going to use this
stick and I'm going to call for this
demon from the Otherworld of invisible
forces you see and he shows up and now
you can wrestle on and it's only then
when you do wrestling that you have the
chance to win but you will also have the
chance to lose oh yeah scary scary scary
there's no way around it and if it's not
scaring you what are we gonna do we're
gonna intense the training we're gonna
pick it up we want that demon here we
want to call it out okay so keep up the
hard work
stay centered go through all your stress
management skills you have to I don't
recommend coming into training when you
haven't slept right eat right sleep
right come to training ready to do
battle with that demon if you were in
poor shape because you didn't practice
the necessary sacrifices that you needed
to practice you're gonna learn the hard
way it's not the best way to learn it's
effective but it's not the best way hey
so do everything you need to do because
you know what you're gonna end up doing
put everything as much as you can on
your side set yourself up for possible
success not for inevitable failure right
I know some of you come here last second
I don't know how you do it like mentally
last second you show up oh yeah well
trained cuz I always see it on your face
oh [\h__\h] I forgot he's a [\h__\h] he's
gonna hit me hard you know what I mean
it's always on your face I don't know
why you do it you should know you should
drive here knowing I don't feel like
doing it I know he don't feel like doing
it but he's going to do it you
understand that I I get the surprise
face is always a mystery to me I always
feel like shaking hello my name is Dave
I trained for real do you know what I'm
saying some of you look like you come to
class like that today I'm thick today
he's not going to do it I think today
we're gonna train
for fake and I'm gonna get to walk
through this I don't know why you're
doing right so come ready to train ready
to wrestle with that demon because I'm
going to exorcise him out into the open
[Music]